pareo Keung a visit to this square in
central Seoul brings back many memories
every week she joined hundreds of
thousands of others here to protest
against former president Park all of
them wanted what they call a corrupt
system to change the kingdom okay no
this was the first time I saw such a
large gathering it was both shocking and
at the same time a great experience to
see so many people come out together for
one cause I had no idea so many thought
like I did bravely stepping up and
coming out to express their views da da
da by RT ho ho I'll get it on with you
after months of demonstrations they
succeeded the president was forced out
of office it was an important milestone
but in the eyes of many not yet the
final goal
even though former president Park
geun-hye was impeached months ago many
South Koreans are still unhappy because
they feel a corrupt political and
business elite is still at the helm
making decisions that are not in their
best interest we meet some of ryuk
Young's new friends at a cafe they got
to know each other at the protests they
agree the demonstrations were just the
first step table reward on Tong in Korea
the big companies and the government
have a very close relationship wrong and
it shouldn't be that way on Daniel I
wish that would completely disappear
also the justice system is corrupt that
should be eradicated too so there can be
justice in Korea the friends know the
old structures won't change overnight
but they've already noticed one major
difference which paranasal the protest
is sparked interest in politics people
are paying attention to the elections
and they are debating among themselves
protests have kindled a flame I don't
think that will die down anytime soon
solidarity Nanako
singular KD iyanya tell friends and I'll
follow even though we might have
different opinions on the way everyone
can express why they're supporting a
certain candidate Jaeger saying I think
the political atmosphere has already
become much more democratic tonk chisel
Woodall Tom Devine Joe Dorgan amico
catatonic in Rio Young's life not
everything is different from before she
still likes to hang out with her friends
and go shopping but the protests did
alter her mindset I care about what's
going on now I won't stop paying
attention to politics even after the
election even if the candidate I support
wins
I'll watch very closely what he does if
something happens that I don't agree
with
I'll come out again and voice my opinion
otherwise nothing will change South
Koreans have a long history of standing
up to those in power
it seems that legacy has now been passed
on to the next generation young and her
friends have realized that it's up to
them what shape South Korea's democracy
will take in the future